so one of the one of my like probably
the deepest passion for me what I would
say maybe what kind of spoke off mic a
little bit about it but that that I
think is a blind spot for at least
robotics and AI folks is human robot
interaction human agent interaction
maybe idea of thoughts about how we
reduce the size of that blinds but do
you also share the feeling that not
enough folks are studying this aspect of
interaction well I I'm I'm actually
pretty intensively interested in this
issue now and there are people in my
group who've actually pivoted pretty
hard over the last few years from doing
more traditional cognitive psychology
and cognitive neuroscience to doing
experimental work on human agent
interaction and there are a couple of
reasons that I'm pretty passionately
interested in this one is it's kind of
the outcome of having thought for a few
years now about what we're up to
like what were you think what are we
doing like what what is this what is
this aid AI research for so what does it
mean to make the world a better place I
think I'm pretty sure that means making
life better for humans yeah and so how
do you make life better for humans
that's that's a proposition that when
you look at it carefully and honestly is
rather horrendously complicated
especially when the AI systems that
you're that you're building are learning
systems they're not you're not you know
programming something that you then
introduced to the into the world and it
just works as programmed like Google
Maps or something we're building systems
that learn from experience so you know
that that typically leads to AI safety
questions how do we keep these things
from getting out of control
how do we keep them from doing things
that harm humans and
I mean I hasten to say I consider those
hugely important issues and there are
large sectors of the research community
a deep mind and of course elsewhere who
are dedicated to thinking hard all day
every day about that but there's a
there's I guess I guess I would say a
positive side to this too which is to
say well what would it mean to make
human life better oh and and how how can
we imagine learning systems doing that
and and in talking to my colleagues
about that we reached the initial
conclusion that it's not sufficient to
philosophize about that you actually
have to take into account how humans
actually work and what humans want and
the difficulties of knowing what humans
want and the difficulties that arise
when humans want different things and
and so human agent interaction has
become you know a quite a quite
intensive focus of my group lately if
for no other reason that in order to
really address that that issue in an
adequate way you have to I mean
psychology becomes part of the picture
yeah and then so there's a few elements
there so if you focus on solving it like
the if you focus on the robotics problem
let's say AGI without humans in the
picture is you're missing fundamentally
the final step you when you do want to
help human civilization you eventually
have to interact with humans and when
you create a learning system just as you
said that will eventually have to
interact with humans the interaction
itself has to be become has to become
part of the learning process right so
you can't just watch well my sense is it
sounds like your sense is you can't just
watch humans to learn about humans yeah
you have to also be part of the human
world you have to interact with humans
yeah exactly and I mean then questions
arise that start imperceptibly but
inevitably to slip beyond the realm of
engineering
so questions like if you have an agent
that can do something that you can't do
under what conditions do you want that
agent to do it so you know if you know
if I if I have a if I have a robot that
can play Beethoven sonatas better than
any human in the sense that the you know
the the sensitivity the the express the
expression is just beyond what any human
do I do I want to listen to that do I
want to go to a concert and hear a robot
play these are these are these are an
engineering questions these are
questions about human preference and
human culture and psychology boarding
and philosophy yeah and then and then
you start asking well well even if we
knew the answer to that is it our place
as AI engineers to build that into these
agents probably the agents should
interact with humans beyond the
population of AI engineers and figure
out what those humans want yeah and then
you know when you start I referred this
the moment ago but even that becomes
complicated be quote what if what if 2-8
what if two humans want different things
and you have only one agent that's able
to interact with them and try to satisfy
their preferences then you're into the
realm of of of like economics and and
social choice theory and and even
politics so there's a sense in which if
you if you kind of follow what we're
doing to its logical conclusion then it
goes beyond questions of engineering and
technology and you know starts to shade
and perceptibly into questions about
what kind of society do you want and
actually that once once that dawned on
me I actually felt I don't know what the
right word is quite refreshed in my in
my involvement in AI research it's
almost like this building this kind of
stuff is gonna lead us back to asking
really fundamental questions about
what's you know what is this like look
what's the good life and who gets
to decide and and you know you know
bringing in viewpoints from multiple sub
communities to help us you know shape
the way that we live this it's it's
there's something it it started making
me feel like doing a a I research in in
a fully responsible away would you know
could potentially lead to a kind of like
cultural renewal yeah
it's it's the way done it's the it's the
way to understand human beings at the
individual at the societal level it may
become a way to answer all the silly
human questions of the meaning of life
and all the all of those kinds of things
but if it doesn't even if it doesn't
give us a way of answering those
questions it may force us back to
thinking about thinking about you know
and it might bring it it might bring it
might restore a certain I don't know a
certain depth to or even dare I say
spirituality to the way that you know to
to to the world I don't think maybe
that's too grandiose but well I don't
think I am with you I think it's a it's
a I will be that's what the philosophy
of the 21st century the way the which
will open the door I think a lot of AI
researchers are afraid to open that door
of exploring the view beautiful richness
of the human agent interaction human AI
interaction I'm really happy that
somebody like you have opened to that
door and I think one thing I often think
about is you know the the the usual the
usual schema for thinking about human
human agent interaction is this kind of
dystopian you know oh you know where our
robot overlords and and again I hasten
to say AI safety is usually very and I
you know I'm not saying we shouldn't be
thinking about those risks totally on
board for that but there's a what having
said that there's a there's a I what
often follows for me is the thought that
you know there's another there's another
kind of narrative that might be relevant
which is when we think of when we think
of Hugh
gaining more and more information about
you know like human life the the
narrative there is usually that they've
gained more and more wisdom and more you
know they get closer to enlightenment
and you know and they become more
benevolent and you know like the Buddha
is like the like that's that's a totally
different narrative and why isn't it the
case that we imagine that the the AI
systems that we're creating and just
kind of like they're gonna figure out
more and more about the way the world
works and the way the humans interact
and they'll they'll become beneficent
I'm not saying that will happen I'm not
you know III I'm I don't honestly expect
that to happen without some careful
setting things up very carefully but
it's another way things could go right
and yeah and I would even push back on
that I believe that the most
trajectory's natural human trajectories
will lead us towards progress so for me
there is a kind of sense that most
trajectories in AI development will lead
us into trouble
you mean and and we over focus on the
worst case it's like the in computer
science theoretical computer science has
been this focus on worst-case analysis
there's something appealing to our human
mind at some lowest level to be mean we
don't want to be eaten by the tiger I
guess so we want to do the worst-case
analysis but the reality is that
shouldn't stop us from actually building
out all the other trajectories which are
potentially leading to all the positive
worlds all the all the Enlightenment
this book in language now with Steven
Pinker and so on this is looking
generally at human progress and there's
so many ways the human progress can
happen with the eyes and I think you
have to do that research you have to do
that work you have to do the not just AI
safety work of the one worst-case
analysis how do we prevent that but the
the actual tools and the glue and the
mechanisms of human AI interaction that
would lead to all the positive yeah
Shingo yes super exciting area right
yeah you know we should be spending we
should be spending a lot of our time
saying
what can go wrong I think it's harder to
see that there's work to be done to
bring into focus the question of what
what it would look like for things to go
right yeah it's you know that's not
obvious there in we wouldn't be doing
this if we didn't have the sense there
was huge potential right we're not doing
this you know you know for no reason we
we have a sense that AG I would be a
major boom to humanity but I think I
think it's worth starting now even when
our technology is quite primitive asking
well exactly what would that mean we can
start now with applications that are
already gonna make the world a better
place like you know solving protein
folding you know III think this deep
mind has gotten heavy into science
applications lately which i think is you
know you know a wonderful wonderful move
for us to to be making but when we think
about AG I when we think about building
you know fully intelligent agents that
are gonna be able to in a sense do
whatever they want
you know we should start thinking about
what do we want them to want what what
what kind of world do we want to live in
that's not an easy question and if you
think we just need to start working on
it and even on the path to sort of it
doesn't have to be AG I was just
intelligent agents that interact with us
and help us enrich our own existence on
social networks for example and
recommender systems and various
intelligence there's so much interesting
interaction that's yet to be understood
and studied and yeah how how do you
create I mean
Twitter's is struggling with this very
idea how do you create AI systems that
increase the quality in the health of a
conversation for sure yeah it's a
beautiful beautiful human psychology
question and how do you do that without
without deception being involved without
manipulation being involved you know
maximizing human autonomy and how do you
how do you make these choices in a
democratic way how do you how do we how
do we face the how do we again I'm
speaking for myself here how do we face
the fact
that it's a small group of people who
have the skillset to build these kinds
of systems but the you know what it
means to make the world a better place
is something that we all have to be
talking about yeah the kind of the world
the that we're trying to make a better
place includes
a huge variety of different kinds of
people
yeah how do we cope with that this is
this is a problem that has been
discussed you know in in Gori extensive
detail in social choice theory you know
there one thing I'm really enjoying
about the recent direction work has
taken in some parts of my team is that
yeah we're reading the IEEE literature
we're reading the neuroscience
literature but we've also started
reading like economics and as I
mentioned social choice theory even some
political theory because it turns out
that it's you know it all becomes
relevant it all becomes relevant and but
you know at the same time we've been
trying not to write philosophy papers
right we've been trying not to write
position papers we're trying to figure
out ways of doing actual empirical
research that kind of take the first
small steps to thinking about what it
really means for humans with all of
their complexity and contradiction and
you know paradox you know to be bought
and to be brought into contact with
these API systems in a way that then it
really makes the world a better place
often reinforcement learning frameworks
actually kind of allow you to to do that
machine learning and so that that's the
exciting thing about AI is allows you to
reduce the unsolvable problem
philosophical problem into something
more concrete you can get a hold of yeah
and it allows you to kind of define the
problem in some way that allows for
growth in the system that sort of beat
you know you're not responsible for the
details right you say this is generally
what I want you to do and then learning
takes care of the rest
of course the safety issues are you know
arise in that context but I think also
some of these positive issues arise in
that context what would it mean for an
AI system
to really come to understand what humans
want and you know in if you know in with
all of the subtleties of that right you
know humans humans want help with
certain things but they don't want
everything done for them right there is
you part of part of the satisfaction
that humans get from life is in
accomplishing things so if there were
devices around that did everything for
him you know I often think of the movie
wall-e
yeah that's like dystopian in a totally
different ways like the machines are
doing everything for us that's that's
not what we want it um you know anyway I
just I find this you know this kind of
this opens up a whole landscape of
research that feels affirmative yeah and
his like TV is one of the most exciting
and it's wide open yeah
you